et vous interroger sur la
sous-déclaration en pharmacovigilance
qui en effet est une question récurrente
et on le sait il y a une sous
déclaration en pharmacovigilance mais en
moins sur cette campagne d'une ampleur
inédite nous sommes à la mi novembre à
plus de 110000 déclaration d'effets
indésirables pour vous donner un ordre
de grandeur les années sans pandémie si
je puis dire on est plutôt autour de 45
mille événements indésirables qui sont
enregistrées dans la base nationale de
vigilance donc tout médicament
confondues exactement alors que la sur
les sols des effets indésirables des
vaccins on est à plus de 110000 j'ai
envie bien même s'il daigne
sous-déclaration on est quand même très
largement informés et la surveillance
porte véritablement sur l'ensemble des
effets juste quelques caractéristiques
également sur ses effets c'est vrai que
en règle générale pareil la déclaration
est
majoritairement sept ans par les
professionnels de santé du fait de la
proximité notamment les centres
régionaux de pharmacovigilance des
professionnels de santé au sein des
centres hospitaliers universitaires - on
le voit au lieu d'être a autour de 90%
de déclaration par les professionnels de
santé il ya un rééquilibrage on a
beaucoup plus de déclaration par les
patients on est en train de regarder les
chiffres on pourra vous les donnez plus
tard mais c'est sans doute de l'ordre de
40 60 % 40 % de patients contre 10%
d'habitude et de fait sur la répartition
également entre les cas graves et les
cas graves là aussi on est
habituellement sur une répartition qui
est
autour de
40% de
2,2
pardon il faut que j'arrête là on a
beaucoup plu au gras majoritairement
grave en temps normal et là on n'a plus
une déclaration de d'événements non
graves donc on le voit on a une
surveillance qui fonctionne à la fois
pour les effets indésirables graves et
les noms grave juste pour revenir sur ce
critère de gravité
parce que ça peut engendrer des
problèmes d'incompréhension la gravité
en pharmacovigilance elle est analysée
au regard de certains critères par
exemple si on est hospitalisé s'il a une
maison j'ai du pronostic vital ou un
décès mais il ya aussi un critère qui
est un critère qui est du fait du
professionnel de santé qui va lui jugé
que c'est médicalement que l'effet
médicalement grave et donc de ce fait
c'est un critère qui est important bien
évidemment mais qui recouvre un peu plus
de subjectivité que les critères
hospitalisation par exemple ou décès et
donc vous poser une question par rapport
aux déclarations des faits graves et
qu'elle était assez ses échecs grave qui
étaient majoritairement déclaré donc
encore une fois c'est très vite et elle
correspond à 7 à la définition que je
vous ai rappelé mais il faut aussi
comprendre les madame latine elle a dit
que les les effets déclaré et les
déclarations sont ensuite analysés donc
par les centres régionaux de
pharmacovigilance qui va qui vont
déterminer si effectivement les faits et
bien lié au vaccin parfois ça peut être
lié à la vaccination par exemple on
arrive on est impressionné alors donc
c'est pas forcément liés au vaccin en
lui-même et c'est tout le travail
évidemment des centres que de regarder
ce lien est d'établir cette imputabilité
et donc pour pour en finir et j'ai
tellement on a très majoritairement en
termes d'effets graves mais avec cette
gravité que je vous ai rap est donc ce
critère médicalement grave qui est porté
par les professionnels de santé on a
beaucoup d'effets graves qui recouvre
les symptômes pseudo grippaux c'est à
dire les céphalées la fièvre c'est ce
qui en déclarations entre guillemets
brut si je peux dire ressort alors on a
également pour communal communes et
rebâti pardon l'hypertension artérielle
on a évidemment pour
modern art dont les invite par exemple
mais très majoritairement dans son fait
le top 3 ce sont des effets qui sont
liés au syndrome pseudo grippaux
par contre si effectivement on veut
parler des effets graves qui sont liés
au vaccin est bien là évidemment c'est
ce que l'on va trouver dans le résumé
des caractéristiques du produit parce
que là dans ce document sont évidemment
après analyse non seulement des de
chacun des états mais après comme le
disait critères ati mener une analyse
commune au niveau européen on va
effectivement jugé que la lécher est
effectivement lié au vaccin est qu'il
faut effectivement porté cette
information à l'attention des
professionnels de santé et du public et
donc il va se retrouver dans ce document
de résumés des caractéristiques des
produits et là vous allez retrouver les
fameuses
thrombocytopénie thrombo embolique
immunitaire induite par le vaccin les
fameux vide c'est un univers enfin bon
bref
que l'on avait pour les vaccins à des
noah adénovirus notamment et vous allez
retrouver ces faits très graves qui ne
ressortent pas nécessairement disons le
le top des déclarations parce que en
effet pas la même volumétrie et pas
nécessairement de lien avec le vaccin
sur ces déclarations qui sont faites par
nous tous en première intention
voilà pour les quelques chiffres que je
pourrais vous donner
[Musique]
pour son peu le dominer au coeur dit par
exemple
myocarde c'est un sujet important ça
mais myocarde et or les vaccins donne de
myocardite et combien nous en avait
qu'un
fond concernant même si c'est cela a été
dit par sigmund est donc on a à peu près
sans vie ni les chiens désirable pour
plus de 100 millions d'injections tous
vaccins confondus donc ça c'est déjà on
est chez ça permet en effet de
d'appréhender à la fois un nombre à un
nombre sans limite indésirable tout va
un peu plus de 110000 tous vaccins
confondus pour plus de 100 millions
d'injections si on regarde sur les plans
si on regarde en effet sur les quatre
vaccins autorisés donc est utilisé sur
le territoire national le premier donc
comme airmatic est le facteur le vaccin
avons failli therby ventech on a plus de
80 millions de plus de 80 millions
d'injections vous voyez sur les 100
millions il est très très majoritaire on
à 68000 cas déchets d'effets
indésirables si nous prenons moderna
donc le spike vax
à peu près un petit peu plus de 11
millions de 11 millions d'injections
vous avez quinze mille cas déchets
indésirables
sur le vaccin adénovirus vague d'evry ya
donc d'astrazeneca à peu près 8 millions
d'injections 27000 cas déchets déchets
indésirables et le vaccin johnsen qui a
été peu utilisé on a un tout petit peu
plus d'un million d'injection et nous
avons mille cas d'effets indésirables
donc comme cela a été a été rappelé donc
on a beaucoup de cas en effet soit de
syndrome monsieur de syndrome pseudo
clip oh uh uh quelques signes quelques
quelques effets en effet avec terme de
basculer si on regarde en effet des
myocardite de mémoire nous avons à peu
près un petit peu plus de un petit peu
moins de 500 cas au total de 4,2 mieux
car dit
donc avec les vaccins arn messager comme
je l'indiquais donc à la fois le vaccin
comme dermatite
le vaccin combien y at-il de pfizer
bayonne tech et le vaccin spike vax donc
de deux moderna et donc avec eux à peu
près 300 75,4 pour le bac 5 aubière nati
donc y est très majoritairement utilisé
est un petit peu plus d'une centaine de
cas qu'on le vaccin moderne a donc on le
voit bien et c'est ce qui a été démontré
c'est ce que j'ai indiqué précédemment
et c'est déclassé en effet indiqué à la
fois dans le résumé des caractéristiques
des produits et de nautisme c'est un
méchant indésirables qui a été reconnue
donc avec un lien possible entre cet
effet indésirable et la vaccination avec
les arn messagers des vaccins arn
messager qui n'ont pas été retrouvés
pour les vaccins adénovirus
les vaccins des navires us comme cela a
été dit précédemment il ya en effet de
signal sur les thromboses atypique rend
donc ces cas de myocardite sont des cas
donc de résolution favorable donc la
très très grande majorité des cas
analysés léman je parle au niveau
national mais aussi au niveau européen
puisque évidemment tout cela a été
partagée l'échangé au niveau européen on
voit qu'il y à une sangle y avoir une
fréquence plus importante de myocardite
avec le vaccin moderne à comparer aux
vaccins pfizer donc ça a été vu au
travers notamment de données
préliminaires d'une étude scandinave qui
a été réalisé mais surtout nous avons pu
le mettre en évidence donc avec le jc
pichard avec l'étude épiphane où on voit
en effet une différence il y as dvd
myocardite avec ses deux vaccins mais
une fréquence plus importante avec le
vaccin monument et c'est ce qui a
conduit notamment la haute autorité de
santé à prendre une recommandation
d'utilisation des vaccins des vaccins
moderna donc de sfax plutôt chez les
adultes à partir de 30 ans qu'il faut
savoir que la myocardite
en effet la myocardite et d'occurrence
souvent une étiologie aviales avec une
une surreprésentation en effet des mieux
car dit chez notamment les jeunes les
hommes ah bon et chez les jeunes hommes
et donc avec une concentration plus
importante en effet deux cas notamment
chez les 18 18 29 ans et c'est la raison
c'est la raison pour laquelle en échelle
notamment dans le cadre de la stratégie
vaccinale qui n'est pas de sous l'égide
de l'année siam et de la haute autorité
de santé à la faveur de l'ensemble des
données et notamment des données des
petits fans il ya eu cette
recommandation de plutôt utilisé modern
age chez les plus de 30 ans donc c'est
vraiment tout le cheminement c'est à
dire qu'on détecte un effet indésirable
en pharmacovigilance on regarde ce qu'il
se passe aussi en taille de l'effet en
pharmaco épidémiologie ça permet d'aider
en effet à l'utilisation et à la
décision donc voilà en ce qui concerne
et au fur et à mesure les choses
s'incrémente c'est à dire que nous
suivons continuellement est là comme le
disait en effet céline bonnier nous
avons des déclarations 110000
déclaration en effet c'est 3,2 par
rapport
année par rapport à une année classique
va je dirais hors crise pour la
pharmacovigilance on a à peu près à
45000 déclaration tout médicament
confondues là uniquement sur les vaccins
disque est assez normal nous avons en
effet plus de 52 millions de personnes
qui ont reçu un schéma à schéma vaccinal
complet donc de ce fait évidemment il y
a ça témoigne aussi du bon
fonctionnement et de la déclaration et
on a beaucoup communiqué sur la
déclaration la possibilité de
déclaration des effets indésirables et
de la déclaration d'intérêts des effets
atypique tant attendu que c'est ça qui
est important
[Musique]